good afternoon sir my name is Rebecca
Mitchell I'm originally from Dallas
Texas currently living in the
Netherlands and my question is regarding
your work that you received the Nobel
Prize from I'm interested in seeing what
you think the implications are for your
work on today's society what what kind
of effect do you think what you your
work is done is having on the everyday
person thank you very much Rebecca
you're asking one of the questions
that's goes to the heart of why do
people do science the part that I work
on is pretty nearly pure science pure
astronomy has a very important cultural
effect as helping us understand our
place in the universe and our history
people have a deep passion for wanting
to know how we got here and where are we
going and I think that's part of being
human to want to know people have been
drawing pictures on cave walls for
30,000 years and trying to go to the
afterlife for at least 5,000 years so we
care about how it really works how's the
universe organized and so part of the
appeal of astronomy is it tells us a
beautiful story about how we got here
and it's probably true in many respects
we now have a story about how the
universe started how galaxies are formed
how stars are formed how the chemical
elements are formed how the planet earth
could be formed and how it could come to
be capable of supporting life with just
the right amounts of water and carbon
dioxide and oxygen and other things that
we treasure and and live from here so
that's one part of the story the other
part is that in a modern technological
society everything we do is controlled
by scientific knowledge and engineering
application of that knowledge and
management systems and cultural
organizations that put that information
to use so it's part of becoming literate
human beings that we depend on knowledge
of every branch of science and astronomy
is one of the few that has such a deep
cultural impact upon us